welcome to this video playing the cross
shark from the UK it's very relatively
high rated and have played him four
times I don't remember this fifty
percent okay the beauty of this low
rating is that I to actually win points
by by some drawers and host games so and
the winners really am having some some
impact if I should manage one yeah
typical closer ruler pest position play
my usual set up here now this is play
but wait I can a 385 hmm he's not
threatening anything it's not a big
problem if the Queen side is closed
ready the defensive position on the King
side is very very reliable I'm playing
98 to f7 basically gaining a tempo on
the bishop white absolutely yeah not
absolutely but almost never will take on
g7 this is giving up too much of the
dark squares very often Bishop g7 beg
fires because of that
oh he's he is actually allowing that
what yeah but okay this this should up
should be okay for me if he takes now
okay a five yeah it would be nice if I
could get in Bishop f8 to h6 of course I
wonder if this is possible at all rook
h8 bishop f ed maybe Queen g4 is not not
a big problem okay maybe I can clarify
the issue on the queenside first there's
nothing happening here quickly anyway at
least I don't see it I could also think
about taking on f5 at the right moment
this might be it might be a move but
only if I really get the bishop out of
my pawn shine like by F 6 h-6 f8 h6
okay he wants to close the Queen said I
really don't mind that very often the
queenside opens some in whites favor
long-term I mean okay well he cannot
take there is a pin and maybe I can get
in Luke h8 rook g8 King f88 Bishop f8
yeah look a 2g eight can I get this n I
think I can the check on age five is not
a problem i can go to F aid they cannot
take here anyway because the Queen hangs
the idea is king f 88 and then Bishop f8
to h6 if possible yeah it's a obviously
a very closed position so um back back
up to f8 takes takes
my chief I I don't want to take rally
right okay it's not two not much else
here
maybe takes takes Knight g4 I can go now
gt5 first
a 95 could be could be interesting my G
495 I can go here and he needs to stay
on the night I guess otherwise I'll take
it and damage the spawn structure really
seriously so you must go here the
question is do I have some good move
here Bishop a Quincy eight maybe maybe
Quincy aid if you move the night away I
candle they can sacrifice probably no
it's not it's not totally crazy maybe to
sacrifice on age three
and I don't think it's it's flat it's
flat winning but it's very nice maybe
you look age fryer just threatening we
should be four again and double double
on the edge farm
peace I can take on age three now but
then Knight f6 okay
or should I sacrifice the exchange is
not it's not a bad bad position after
that after I can also think of rook h8
actually Knight f6 look F 497 27 and
then a sacrifice and it's tough to tough
too tough to evaluate come on let's
let's do that I hope I'm not overlooking
something stupid because the position is
obviously very good for black okay so
it's not not taking here can I go King
g7 simply Knight f6 look at form and why
not
rook h3 would be nice to get in he takes
Knight takes wins the Queen
no Knight f6 rook inform time money so
why can I get in a sacrifice now come
cats let's let's try let's try 9f to my
queen is a bit a bit too far away it's
not really not really playing a big part
of this what about Bishop takes a 4 and
Queen h3 or something this working know
this Bishop here and came difficult
Knight a5 business silly no check no in
to rupture ah come on I know does this
is this is really black resign I mean
what could totally outplayed I mean like
totally just I'm just not in good shape
here always be frustrating if you look
at it with a computer King g7 so what
wins now rook takes wins and it's
actually really easy really easy then
one minute against 30 seconds and then I
play the wrong sacrifice you have I what
I did what I overlooked is that I'm
simply taking here this is this is in
fact a very easy win yeah why it has no
alternative to that and then one night
is coming here and I've got f5 to ship
g5 yeah something like that it's just
such a soapless for white check yeah
this was the wrong sacrifice but it
seems to defend until very well actually
it didn't f5 still wins Queen g8 also
wins okay this is not winning rook edge
one again is winning yeah and just play
like a [ __ ] him yeah and then then I
ran into this into this fork and okay
heads it's just lost and I'm now down on
time yeah yeah I simply don't believe in
this giving up the
one g 7 this is some very very decent
defensive set up for black where he's
never worse and the way he played it he
was just just clearly clearly clearly
worse with this Knight g4 this is all
not really fitting into the position I
just need to take with the right piece
on age three and then this game is
decided according to them the previous
the way it went previously like Windsor
with a nice attack boom okay thanks for
watching